an estimated one in 20 people who
suffered from the disease are so-called
covet long-haulers that means they
recovered from their initial illness but
often have debilitating symptoms for
weeks or even months
many can't go back to work and face
severe financial hurdles
as part of our series medical price
roulette in collaboration with clear
health costs
our consumer investigative correspondent
anna warner looks at some of the
challenges they face
anna good morning to you yeah good
morning the long covered patients we
spoke to
say they're sometimes so disabled by
symptoms they can't get out of bed
but if they can't go back to work how do
they survive financially
it is day 154 from me
and i am considered a covert long hauler
that was candace taylor of atlanta last
august
struggling to speak her covid19
infection happened in march 2020
but she says she still has breathing
issues and other symptoms
i am pretty much disabled i can't
do small tests that we take for granted
i can't clean
my house without severe chest pain
shooting throughout my body covid hit
kelly keaney
of new jersey over a year ago too now
she says
the fatigue and pain have turned her
into a different person
i don't look like that anymore i do not
look healthy
i and i don't feel healthy
emotionally or physically malaina
barcenas is an industrial janitor in
detroit
i get tired very easily still hi
barcenas gave birth to her daughter
about 16 months ago while suffering from
covid
and in a coma the walking is the biggest
issue
going from the door to the car that can
tire me out like for the whole day
doctors diagnosed all three women with
what's often called
long covet we're dealing with a syndrome
that we know is quite devastating dr avi
natt is studying
long-covered patients at the national
institutes of health or nih
how disabling can this be it can be
very severe many people cannot work any
longer so they lost their job
and now they are unemployed keaney knows
about that
when dogs have a job to do they're not
bored
and barking she's lost both her jobs her
personal dog training business
and the full-time mortgage processing
job that paid the bills
she says she tried to return to that job
until the day she says her boss told her
she was making too many mistakes
you've been with me 27 years you don't
make the same mistake and you certainly
don't make them twice
you're not remembering what i tell you
to do she's been out on disability with
her boss's support for almost 10 months
but no one can say how long that's going
to last
do you have any assurance right now that
you are going to be able to go back to
work
no barcenas is on disability too
but says her payments are roughly half
her usual salary and she lost her health
insurance in september
two weeks after that i got a bill for
physical therapy for almost three
thousand dollars
it was like and no real idea of how to
pay it right
exactly they're the kind of stories
connecticut employment law attorney gary
phelan hears a lot
i think they're people facing the most
enormous challenge of their lives
phelan says many of his clients with
long covid can't work
but have trouble even getting disability
payments from the insurance plans
provided by their employers
candace taylor for example it has been
a tug of war with the insurance company
she worked at a hospital that provides
disability insurance
but even though her doctor diagnosed her
with postcovid syndrome
the insurance company fought her claim
in march they sent this letter denying
short-term benefits even claiming in
part falsely taylor says
that she had a psychosomatic illness in
other words one
all in her mind i never thought i would
have to suffer for
benefits that i worked for are a lot of
insurance companies turning down
people's disability claims i think
generally that has been the case
a lot of them are based on you know
symptoms that it's hard to define
they change over time unlike the nature
of other medical conditions
and so because of that uncertainty it
gives
really insurance companies uh more you
know
more of an ability to deny claims at the
time of our interview
taylor said she was three months behind
on her rent
and had gotten two eviction notices
there's days where i'm sad there's days
where
i want to give up but i know i can't
give up
there's a small part of me that just has
to keep fighting
kelly keaney tries to keep her spirits
up too but says what really hurts most
is losing the dog training business she
loved
that she hoped would eventually become
her full-time livelihood
and i don't know if i'm going to be able
to reopen my business
it breaks my heart really does
well taylor fought her insurance company
new york life for nearly a year
the company wouldn't discuss her case
with us citing privacy and
confidentiality concerns
but just two days after we contacted
them she was approved
for both short and long-term disability
well that's good news i mean they can
imagine the slap in the face when you're
paying a company to protect you and then
they say oh your illness is all in your
head that's quite the insult
uh what is the main stumbling block for
these people trying to pursue their
disability claims
well i think part of the problem is this
syndrome is so new everybody's still
learning about it and so employers and
probably to some degree the insurance
companies
are still catching up with this the
other part as the attorney pointed out
is
the symptoms can change from day to day
you know there's so many
it's a variety of symptoms and so an
insurance company might say well you
know what we just don't
see where the consistent diagnosis is
here so we're not going to approve your
claim
are legislators willing to step in here
yeah so the nih
has they've congress gave the nih more
than a billion dollars
for research and possible treatments and
the nih
and cdc doctors also say another key
here
is educating doctors treating physicians
to how this plays out what are the
symptoms what do you look for yeah
it's so scary because there's so much
that's unknown i mean you think you get
it
and you survive and yet you still have
these problems i really do hope that
they all just hang on i felt from this
taylor and yeah
i really did and you think if you have a
letter from your doctor then you're
going to be okay with your insurance
company but clearly that's not always
the case
no and and you have to a lot of times
one of the pieces of advice here is if
you're suffering through this
try to get yourself a lawyer if you can
somebody who deals with employment law
because this stuff is
tricky yeah that's not what you want to
hear when you're feeling like now
you need to get a lawyer all right anna
thank you very much